Welcome back to your Danish citizenship exam companion.
This is Chapter Three, the final episode, Episode Five: the Danish labour market.
Most people of working age take part in the Danish labour market.
That applies to both men and women.
In 2024, 76.3 percent of the population, the 16 to 66-year-olds, were employed: 78.4 percent of the men and 74.2 percent of the women.
So about three quarters of Danish women are in work.
The Danish labour market is also characterised by a generally well-educated workforce.
For many years it has been the goal that practically everyone should have an education after the folkeskole, although that has not succeeded quite to the extent that was hoped.
On the other hand, Denmark is one of the countries in the world with the strongest tradition for continuing and further education, that is ongoing education during working life.
Education is also more and more necessary, because many of the jobs that do not require education have been taken over by machines or robots, moved abroad, or simply saved away.
Now to the heart of the matter.
People often talk about a special Danish labour market model, which has roots more than 100 years back in time.
During the early industrialisation at the end of the 1800s, a larger working class gradually emerged in the towns.
The workers joined together in trade unions in the various trades, whose overall main organisation is the Danish Trade Union Confederation, FH, which had the purpose of fighting for better pay and working conditions.
In response, the employers joined together in the Danish Employers' Confederation, which today is called DA.
Several of the principles underlying the Danish labour market come from the September Compromise, Septemberforliget, which the parties of the labour market entered into in 1899.
The compromise is therefore also called "the labour market's constitution", Arbejdsmarkedets Grundlov, and means, among other things, that trade unions and employers' organisations recognise each other as entitled to negotiate on behalf of their members.
The two parties can thus enter into agreements that cover several groups of employers and employees.
Such an agreement is called a collective agreement, an overenskomst.
It typically lays down pay and working conditions.
The September Compromise also establishes that it is the employer who manages and distributes the work, and who can hire and dismiss employees.
Finally, the compromise involves a so-called duty of peace, fredspligt.
That means that a strike, when employees lay down their work, and a lockout, when employers send employees home, are not allowed when a collective agreement has been entered into.
Overall, the Danish labour market model is built on these five central elements.
One: the majority of the workforce is organised in trade unions.
Two: the parties of the labour market themselves agree on pay and working conditions on the labour market, which is called self-regulation.
The state, as a main rule, does not interfere in this, as in certain other countries, unless the parties, after many negotiations, do not seem to be able to agree.
Three: a very large part of the labour market is covered by collective agreements.
Four: there is so-called tripartite cooperation between employees, employers and the state about conditions on the labour market.
And five: there is flexibility and security, flexicurity.
It is thus easy to hire and fire employees in Denmark, but the unemployed also get support from the public sector, which is partly self-paid.
Let's take them one at a time.
First, a high degree of organisation.
On the Danish labour market, the large majority of employees are professionally organised, although the share has fallen in recent decades.
Almost two out of three, 68 percent, of employees were in 2025 members of a trade union.
It is almost only the Nordic countries that have such a high degree of organisation.
The trade union works to secure the members the best possible conditions in the workplaces.
There are trade unions both for privately employed and for publicly employed people.
Both the trade unions and the employers' organisations are gathered in nationwide federations and main organisations.
The biggest main organisation is the Danish Trade Union Confederation, FH.
FH is an umbrella organisation for a total of about 600 trade union federations and organises about 1.3 million members.
DA is the employers' main organisation and organises 11 employers' organisations with about 23,000 companies within, among other things, industry, trade, transport, service and construction.
Dansk Industri, DI, the Confederation of Danish Industry, with its 23,000 member companies, which employ about 650,000 employees, is Denmark's biggest employers' and business organisation and DA's biggest member organisation.
The second biggest business organisation is Dansk Erhverv, which represents 18,000 companies, which are often smaller than the companies in DI.
There is freedom of association in Denmark.
That means, among other things, that the individual employee decides for themself whether they want to be a member of a trade union, and if so which one.
It also means that it is forbidden for an employer to dismiss an employee because they are a member of a trade union, just as it is forbidden to dismiss an employee because they are not a member of a trade union.
In connection with new hiring, there must also not be a demand that an employee must be a member of a particular trade union.
Second, self-regulation and collective agreements.
The state thus does not interfere in pay and working conditions as long as the parties are themselves able to enter into agreements in these areas.
The agreements also cover subjects which in most other countries would be decided by laws passed by parliament and government.
That can be working hours, overtime pay, notice periods or minimum wage.
Denmark thus has no statutory minimum wage, but the agreements between trade unions and employers' organisations in reality have the same effect.
Another example is employees' pension, where the parties of the labour market have agreed a labour market pension on top of the old-age pension that the state pays.
In recent years it has also been agreed that full pay including pension is paid in a larger part of the period when you are on parental leave.
It is also the parties of the labour market themselves who seek to solve the conflicts that may arise.
The basic idea is that the parties of the labour market can adapt agreements faster and better to the individual industry or the individual company.
And when the parties themselves have taken part in making an agreement, they also accept its terms.
More than 80 percent of the Danish labour market is covered by collective agreements.
A collective agreement is an agreement between a trade union and an employer or employers' organisation about pay and working conditions within a particular area, which the parties themselves delimit in the agreement.
An employer who has entered into a collective agreement is obliged to give all the employees the pay and working conditions which appear from the agreement.
That applies, for example, to agreements about pay, pension, working hours, holiday and notice.
If the parties do not agree on a new collective agreement when an existing agreement expires, there will be a conflict on the labour market.
That is, the employees strike, or the employer can lock out their employees, send them home from work without pay.
To avert conflicts on the labour market, the state has since 1910 had a so-called Conciliation Institution, Forligsinstitutionen, which is often referred to as "the conciliator", forligsmanden.
The conciliator can, if there is a prospect of conflict between the parties of the labour market, for example summon the parties to negotiations or put forward a so-called mediation proposal, a mæglingsforslag, which is a proposal for a settlement, a compromise, between the parties.
The conciliator can also postpone a threatening labour market conflict, typically by a couple of weeks.
It happens relatively rarely that there is a major conflict on the labour market, but it has happened several times.
The last time there was a major conflict on the private labour market was in 1998.
It meant, for example, that many buses did not run and that the shops did not get goods delivered.
The government and the Folketing have then typically, as they also did in 1998, relatively quickly made a law about a collective agreement, so that the employees return to work and the situation becomes normal again.
In those cases, the Folketing's law has always been based on a mediation proposal which the conciliator on the labour market has put forward.
In that connection, people speak of "raising a mediation outline to law".
Third, and finally, tripartite cooperation and flexicurity.
The state also typically cooperates continuously with the parties of the labour market about shaping the part of the labour market policy that is laid down through legislation.
This applies, for example, to rules about the working environment, job placement, labour market training and unemployment insurance.
This cooperation is called tripartite cooperation, trepartssamarbejde, because it consists of three parties: the state, the employers and the employees.
The cooperation is meant to ensure a labour market that is both flexible for employers and secure for employees.
The flexibility consists of it being relatively easy for employers to dismiss employees when the economy is bad, and to hire employees when things go well.
The security consists of employees having an economic security in the form of unemployment support if they lose their job.
This also makes it less risky to change jobs.
Employees are also secured help to get back to the labour market, for example through education, internships or other activation.
This combination of flexibility and security is often referred to as the Danish flexicurity model.
Here is your recap for Episode Five, and for Chapter Three.
In 2024, 76.3 percent of 16 to 66-year-olds were employed: 78.4 percent of men and 74.2 percent of women.
The labour market model has roots more than 100 years back and rests on the September Compromise of 1899, the labour market's constitution.
Strikes and lockouts are not allowed under a collective agreement, the duty of peace.
The five elements are: high organisation, self-regulation, collective agreements, tripartite cooperation and flexicurity.
In 2025, 68 percent of employees were union members.
FH has about 600 federations and 1.3 million members.
DA has 11 organisations and about 23,000 companies.
DI has 23,000 companies and 650,000 employees; Dansk Erhverv 18,000 companies.
There is freedom of association, and no statutory minimum wage.
More than 80 percent of the labour market is covered by collective agreements.
The conciliator, from 1910, can summon negotiations, propose mediation and postpone a conflict by a couple of weeks.
The last major conflict on the private labour market was in 1998, and the Folketing made a law based on the mediation proposal.
Tripartite cooperation involves the state, employers and employees.
Flexicurity means it is easy to hire and fire, with unemployment support for those who lose their job.
Now it is time for your exam practice.
These are real questions from past Danish citizenship exams on what you just heard.
For each one, I will read the question and the choices, then pause so you can pick your answer, and then I will give you the correct answer.
Question 1.
Who are the contracting parties when collective agreements on, for example, pay, pension and working conditions are made on the private labour market?
Option A: The state and the municipalities.
Option B: The government and civil servants.
Option C: Trade unions and employers' organisations.
[DA] Hvem er aftaleparter, når der skal indgås overenskomster om fx løn, pension og arbejdsforhold på det private arbejdsmarked?  A: Stat og kommuner  |  B: Regering og embedsmænd  |  C: Fagforeninger og arbejdsgiverorganisationer
The answer is C: Trade unions and employers' organisations.
It appeared in the June 2020, June 2022 and May 2023 exams.
[DA] ✔ C: Fagforeninger og arbejdsgiverorganisationer
Question 2.
Who does DA represent when collective agreements are negotiated on the Danish labour market?
Option A: The employers.
Option B: The government.
Option C: The employees.
[DA] Hvem repræsenterer DA, når der skal forhandles kollektive overenskomster på det danske arbejds- marked?  A: Arbejdsgiverne  |  B: Regeringen  |  C: Lønmodtagerne
The answer is A: The employers.
It appeared in the June 2021 exam.
[DA] ✔ A: Arbejdsgiverne
Question 3.
Is the majority of employees on the Danish labour market a member of a trade union?
Option A: Yes.
Option B: No.
[DA] Er flertallet af lønmodtagere på det danske arbejdsmarked medlem af en fagforening?  A: Ja  |  B: Nej
The answer is A: Yes.
It appeared in the June 2022 exam.
[DA] ✔ A: Ja
That's the end of this part.
Well done.